Development of applications for Android
Is an exciting opportunity to change the world.
I'll let you know about the process of starting with Android
Using Android Studio
With some professional tips
Based on the experiences of a truly emerging Android company.
Before we even install Android Studio
You should start thinking about the application you plan to build.
Start by thinking about challenges
That you and your friends and family face.
Can you build an application that can resolve one of these problems?
Let's look at the company's emerging team
We see where their thoughts come from.
Is there anyone inside? Open.
Faster.
open it.
Put something out there.
I just kick it open, come on.
Well, this was unexpected.
what the hell?
What is going on?
Zombie. It must have been zombie.
I do not know how, but I bet that bald guy is somewhat responsible.
Of course.
I solved the problem using Android Nomicon
Suddenly this is my mistake.
How will we survive in a zombie-dominated world?
We are not trained!
It's not like we can go to Google Play
And download an application.
Information # 1: Solve a real problem
Such as our start-up company startup team have a problem you must solve.
So it is time to start development.
First verify that you have version 7 or later
From the Java Development Kit
Open a terminal window or command prompt
And type java-version.
I'm doing this on a Mac, but it should look very similar
On Linux or Windows.
The version number of Java appears after one.
So you can see here.
JDK version 8 is installed for me.
If you see an error or the version is below 7
You will need to download and install JDK.
From this download page, find the Java platform Standard Edition.
Choose Download, and then choose the appropriate set for your operating system.
I am on Mac so I will accept the license agreement.
And download the Mac OSX x64 installer from the Java SE Development Kit.
Once downloaded, find the file
Then click it twice to start the installation process.
Once it is complete, return to your terminal
And make sure they are installed correctly.
You are now ready to install Android Studio.
We'll start by going to the Android Studio home page.
On developer.android.com/sdk.
There is a big button at the top
Download Android Studio.
Click it.
Read now carefully the terms and conditions.
Select the check box to confirm that it is read and approved.
Then click the Download Android Studio button
To start data transfer.
The file is too large,
While waiting for completion,
You have a great chance to start thinking about the APIs
Which you will use to build the application that will solve your problem.
At this early time of the product life cycle
It is useful to explore some of the options available
Using new versions or even early beta versions
Of the Android platform.
Look here for the new APIs available
Available from Android version Marshmallow.
Let us take a look at our emerging company team
While exploring possible possibilities for its application.
- Ian. - What is our situation?
How are you doing?
I'm really glad we took this Dual Boot Chromebook
On our exit.
Google has a set of APIs for site services and maps.
What do you think of the Fitness API?
We need to make sure it works with Android Wear.
Focus!
Zombie!
Is there an API to kill zombies or protect against it or the like?
GPS applications are very popular now.
I can not find anything here
Check your Android Zed version preview.
- What? - Android Zed, Preview.
- What? G.
G, as in the word زيتون.
O Australians!
Hey Americans!
Ah yes. there he is.
So there is a way the zombie user is in the frame now.
It's nice to have this in the support library.
Information # 2: Use the support library
As the download is complete, you're ready to install Android Studio.
If you're using a Mac system like me, double-click the file to open it.
Then drag the Android icon to Applications.
Click the icon twice to launch Android Studio.
for the first time.
If you're on Windows, double-click the download
Will be installed
Similar to what I will show here on Mac
We'll then set a standard installation for Android Studio.
Press Finish to complete the installation
This will start downloading two to three gigabytes
Includes the Android SDK.
This will take some time, so the opportunity to take a break,
Making a cup of tea,
Think of things as how to invest your app.
What do you see about investment?
I feel that billing in the app will be great
For all additional skills and defenses
But the subscription will be very fixed.
Maybe we can try both ways.
To see which one will be more effective.
That's true. This is a good Idea.
Should we worry about performance now?
I mean if you are being stalked by a zombie
We must be responsive. Right?
Right.
So it is clear in our application that we can not use any eNoms
I do not know. Is this a risk of early improvement?
Listen now. We talked--
Okay.
Download finished.
Information # 3: Downloads take a long time
Information # 4: Proactive improvements are not premature
Information # 5: Do not forget the zombie
Well, the download is complete.
Click Finish and the download has been done.
You are now ready to start programming
We will start creating a new Hello World project
You can build it.
Keep in mind that Android Studio
It is constantly updated and improved.
As a result, track the process of your edition
It may look a bit different from what I see on the screen.
do not worry.
Options displayed in the general flow
Should be very similar.
Start by choosing Start a new Android Studio project.
Give it a name and enter a domain.
These two will be used together to form the name of your application package.
The package names must be unique.
So you'd prefer to have a domain and you can use it here.
Even if you do not own one,
Try to identify something that is unlikely to conflict with another developer.
I own a domain, so I'll enter it here.
It suits me to use the default project location.
To continue, click Next
We can now identify the devices we plan to target with our app.
Ultimately, we want to make our app available
In all possible model factors.
But for our first applications
Let's keep it simple and target only phones and tablets.
Then we can determine the minimum SDK we intend to support.
Selecting the Minimum SDK allows you to choose the level of your app
In terms of support for earlier versions.
Low value makes your app available to a number of devices.
But in return it requires more work
To ensure compatibility with devices
Which may not support all added features
In newer Android versions.
You can check to see the ratio of Android devices
That works on every operating system version
By clicking on this help link.
When we shot this video in October 2015
Our support allowed even Android 4.0 or Ice Cream Sandwich
Access to about 90% of the devices.
You will now be asked to select a new activity
Or type a UI screen to add to your project.
Let's start, we'll select an empty activity.
Give it a name and address.
Other files and planning and existing resources
You will be automatically generated.
You can keep your default names.
Then click Finish.
Check out some tips and wait for your new project.
This may take some time the first time you run it.
So we have prepared one in advance.
Your Hello World application is now operational
You can see it working on the emulator
By pressing the green Run button like this
And choose the emulator.
But it's more fun running it on a real Android device.
Enable USB debugging by going to Settings
Get down to About Phone.
Then scroll down, and press the building number seven times.
This will enable developer options.
Go back.
Select developer options, and enable USB debugging from there.
If you are running Windows,
You'll also need to download a driver for your phone.
You can find the necessary drivers and installation instructions
Here on the Android developer site
On developer.android.com/tools/extra/oem-usb
Now connect your phone to your computer,
If prompted, choose Allow errors to be corrected via USB.
Click the Run button in Android Studio
But this time select your real device.
Congratulations.
You are running your first app on a real phone.
Then you're ready to start building a real application,
Unlike this example, you need a lot of time
In a pleasant, responsive and user-friendly experience.
On this occasion, to see what news our company's emerging team.
I ran the app, however, how do I know if it works?
It does not work.
Have you enabled real-time location settings?
Moment, is that the brain icon or the celery stick?
The celery oud.
Then pass down, and press the version number seven times.
Do you understand any of this, Joanna?
I'm sorry. I wanted to tell you, my friends.
I decided to join a different startup company named Meatr
It will link the zombie with two human hosts
Their arrival is achieved by tasty fresh minds on demand.
So it would be great.
But with you right, I probably have to go from here.
Good luck guys.
Information # 6: Good user experience is crucial
She could have left the shelf.
Information # 7: Take the shelf with you always
Unfortunately for our brave young team,
They were late in marketing.
And have experienced some serious problems in their design of the user experience.
You can avoid errors using our resources
To learn how to build and design wonderful Android applications.
good luck.
Meatr delivery.
Hi.
Hello guys.
How are you doing?
Do you know, Colt, we absolutely used eNom to get to the market faster.
Information # 8: Reduce time to market